hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to would you rather you
guys seem to enjoy the last episode and
I enjoy revealing very personal and
disturbing things about my own self so
let's get back to the awesome game that
is would you rather also have um played
for yourself you probably should there's
a lot of good questions out there yeah
okay would you rather be deaf and have
no legs or be blind and have no arms oh
that's a bit of a conundrum I don't know
it all depends on whether or not oh man
but if I like to be able to see but if I
have no arms and how I masturbate heaven
never mind out a better I guess I'll go
with be deaf and have no legs because
then I like being able to see more than
I like being able to hear Wow a lot of
people follow my lead I am a leader of
leading zli leads okay would you rather
raise a family with Samuel Jackson to
raise a family with Vin Diesel is this
even a question of course Samuel is this
because he made the pacifier you dicks
who wouldn't want to raise a family with
Samuel elgianne
would you rather live in the past or
live in the future the past had the
plague the future might not even be
there I want to know what's going on in
the future don't look to the Past look
to keep your eyes on the Hurra
always think forward inspirational
[ __ ] of course would you rather be a
vampire or be a werewolf oh the age-old
question well personally my vision of
vampires is a little ruined because now
I always think of the sparkly vampires
from Twilight but also the vampires from
underworld were kind of whiny sometimes
I don't know I've always had a special
affinity for werewolves because it's
like it all depends on whether you
romanticize one version or another but I
like werewolves that aren't romanticized
like it's a brutal curse that comes out
and unleash like when you're in human
form you have no special abilities like
I think that's what a world would be and
I think that'd be better
OOP hey it's actually evenly split
I'm surprised okay would you rather pull
all of your toenails out or pull all of
your hair out ah why do I have to choose
between the two of those I guess I gotta
go through I guess I gotta go with
toenails I like my hair too much I don't
want to pull out my hair oh I know and
probably be more painful in the end
probably me more disfiguring but I like
my hair too much would you rather have a
giant birthmark covering 78% of your
face or have a two-foot tail wait why
don't you go back to that one what the
hell happened well uh I guess I'd go
with the tail I don't know what happened
would you rather only wear revealing hot
pink clothes or always have to wear
socks and sandals I would love to wear
revealing hot pink clothes so that
everyone could look at my body I don't
have a single hot pink thing yes I do
yeah I gotta go with the pink clothes
the pink clothes are too cool oh come on
socks and sandals are a tragedy I would
look great in hot pink clothes
especially if they're revealing would
you rather perform petty thievery for a
living or perform grand larceny for a
living excuse me while I look up the
definition of grand larceny theft of
personal property having a value above a
legally specified amount well then you
gotta go with grand larceny why would
you go for petty go big or go home to
jail would you rather go toe-to-toe with
Michael Myers who tried to take down
Freddy Krueger well Freddy Krueger is
kind of a psychological demon he affects
your mind Michael Myers
I don't know was Michael Myers he didn't
have any supernatural influence dude he
was just a murderer in a mask not like
Jason I'm pretty sure he was just a
murderer in the mask a very strong
murderer mind you but I'm pretty sure
I'd rather go toe to toe with Michael
Myers and tried to take down Freddy
Krueger and people agree with me would
you rather wake up in a bathtub full of
ice missing a kidney or wake up in a
public bathroom with a handful of
singles and really lazy eye wow this is
the story behind that one do I have a
permanently lazy eye and why the hell is
that situation of thing is that from
something I can live without a kidney
but there's some other questions about
my hygiene coming into play about that
lazy eye and public baths I'm gonna go
with the kidney Hey oh really you don't
the public connotation but I think you
don't know what happened
would you rather only smell like poop or
only smell poop well I mean isn't one
handful of one half a dozen of the [ __ ]
I mean if you only smell like poop you'd
always smell the poop but you'd get used
to your own smell but then everyone else
would be affected by your smell but if
you only smell poop I don't know would
you get used to it does everything smell
like poop it is always gonna be bad but
then you'd actually have people around
you for the rest of your life if you
didn't smell it I gotta go with only
smell poop yeah because if everyone else
smelled me they wouldn't want to be near
me
if you had kids would you rather
regurgitate food to feed them or lick
your children to bathe them ah this is
horrible I regurgitate food if you were
being eaten alive would you rather be
swallowed head first or be swallowed
feet first these took a dark turn I'd
rather not knew none of that ah I guess
head first to end it quicker good golly
jeez
would you rather master every
programming language or master every
spoken language now that's an
interesting one I think I'd go with
programming languages because I would
lead to a lot more skill sets and it
also accounts for everyone in the future
I'm imagining if I know every single
programming language in existence maybe
not in the future but I still gotta go
with programming really oh but think of
all the things you could do I mean you
can learn languages that's like a
passion in and of itself but learning
programming is boring as [ __ ] put your
other P your pants once a day at a
random time or poop your pants once a
day at a random time
well the poop would be much less
convenient but you could plan for both
of them by wearing a diaper the poop
would be a bit more of an inconvenience
oh so I gotta go with P my pants
have you poop it really just randomly is
it at the same time as at randomly
throughout the day so you're just
gripping your chair wherever you go
dreading the fact that
poop will magically appear in your pants
sounds like an exciting left me then
again I'm a freaking weirdo would you
rather be a pokemon trainer or be a
zombie slayer
well zombie slayer would suggest that
the world has gone to [ __ ] and is now
infested with an apocalyptic scenario of
zombies so in this one I gotta go with
the pokemon trainer because I don't want
to live through the horrible horror that
is that apocalypse no really people are
romanticizing zombie slaying would you
rather a beer on Oprah or appear on
Jerry Springer well if I appear on Jerry
Springer I'm gonna have someone be
cheating on me and having my baby or
seven of them having my baby and if I go
on Oprah I might get a car so I'm gonna
go with Oprah would you rather fly like
Superman or travel like spider-man well
considering that in some of the comics
Superman can fly so fast
he travels faster than the speed of
light I'm pretty sure I gotta go to fly
like Superman
it may not be current Canon but it was
Canon and someday and then the
ScrewAttack battle that they used his
most powerful bowmen against Goku it but
if man is Superman that it's too
powerful stupid here here's my me okay
I'm not dropping this here's my main
problem with that ah the thing about
like why I hate Superman there's more
why I hate Superman anything is that ah
I know in some storylines this doesn't
take place but bear in mind Goku as a
character he may be stupid and Team
Fortress 4 star may put a great
portrayal of who Goku is but he earned
his power he earned his power whatever
like stupid riding Goku has stupid
riding too with Super Saiyan oh no Super
Saiyan level
what if Super Saiyan God I don't care
Goku worked hard his entire life to be
more powerful and always loves to fight
for the sake of fighting Superman is a
compromised person not all that noble
period has very very low points and
didn't earn his power he was just born
with it he was
is born super-powerful and then he had
to learn to control whatever [ __ ]
Goku I like better because he like
struggled and earned it and I know there
are Superman scenarios where he did
struggle and whatever but it's so
contrived because he's always gonna win
I guess Goku is always gonna win - but I
hate Superman oh I'm done moving on
stupid if you had to do one every other
year would you rather live completely
alone on an island or be overworked in a
cramped factory hey if I had to do one
every other year you know maybe I could
turn that island into a vacation home
carve out a coconut and naked my wife
never mind I'm gonna go with alone on an
island would you rather have the first
dibs every time or always have the last
laugh huh
well now that's interesting because the
last laugh has connotations so if I have
a masterful plan I will always have the
shut the [ __ ] up I will always have the
last laugh no matter what I do and
that's interesting because being first
is nice and all but just because you
have dibs does not mean that you're
gonna get it no matter what the rules of
dibs are there's always gonna be things
where the rules can be broken so having
the last laugh implies that there's
another way around it if my plan always
interferes and I always have the last
laugh
even if I don't win it every time I've
always have the last lie like that I'm
gonna choose that oh people agree with
me oh okay I thought I was gonna be
unique on that one right there I'm one
of the crowd wake up sheeple hmm would
you rather swallow three jawbreakers or
swallow a footlong candy-cane ooh if you
swallow the footlong candy-cane one
that'd be really hot and sexy but to it
break into shards into your throat maybe
and that wouldn't be good at all I'd
probably make it down okay depends on
your deepthroating skills I [ __ ] and
if the job breakers are like like Edd n
Eddy sighs jaw breakers then that also
implies that it's going to be a bad time
unless you're deepthroating skills are
really
really good I could say I'm going with a
candy cane ah really
oh come on would you rather only speak
in words that begin with H or not be
able to say any words that have the
letter e in them oh he is such a
valuable letter but how many words begin
with H hi hands how have I guess I go
with the letter E in them because if I
come up with a good enough oh cab there
I'd be fine Oh got a goatee oh no how
many words possibly start with H would
you rather open a can of whoop ass on a
fool or pity a fool well I mean I've
dozen oh one two thirds of the clock
open a can of whoop-ass that's me I'm a
bad girl I'm a badass would you rather
be on an episode of cops or be on an
episode of cheaters well if I'm on
cheaters I'm either being cheated on or
I'm cheating on someone and frankly I've
been cheated on before and it is a
horrible experience
I hate cheaters there's no excuse for it
so I got to go on an episode of cops
unless I'm off the episode of cops
because I was on an episode of cheaters
and I had to run away from someone
trying to murder me I'll be on cops I
can't stand cheaters would you rather be
stoned to death or be grounded
are we talking grounded like to my room
or grounded is in some big burly guy
named Sancho takes a sledgehammer if it
happens via the ground
ha ha
that's I the only reason that was funny
to me is because I pictured some big guy
but his head was a baby face cuz they
could give up with the right name big
strong arms and stuff put it
baby and his name with Sancho uh I'll
take being grounded cuz I get to hang
out with son Chu would you rather
communicate with animals or speak every
language fluently okay here's my thing
about communicating with animals some
animals are really dumb so communicating
with them wouldn't really men out to a
whole lot and what if they don't listen
to you
hey animals how are you doing [ __ ] you
man uh I'm very tired speak every
language that's an easy one
would you rather only be able to
teleport to places you've already been
or only be able to teleport to places
you've never been
now that is an interesting one and one
that I will leave to you guys to answer
in the comments below so intrigued me
with your responses thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you think of this series and you want to
see more episodes of this I love playing
this game it's really really fun to
explore the depths of my own insanity so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
I've got a lot really ah now I look like
an [ __ ]